[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quarante-huit heures à miami l'émission
a trouvé de blanque
[Musique]
ce rock
et bla
on est à woods c'est un quartier des
arceaux
je pense que potentiellement il peut y
avoir zéro complètement déglingué
évidemment c'est alors on m'a donné ce
truc là bas se casser la gueule
c'est très pratique en plus si je
voulais partager la voie publique
ça a fait tilt dans l'histoire
[Musique]
devant lui
oui
au dos on n'est pas censé aller voir
rome
[Musique]
ac
m
bon bah j'abandonne de toute façon je
trouverai jamais je rentre à paris ça
sert à rien
[Musique]
48 heures a mis m
aude a même réussi à interviewer toute
l'équipe de big match pour découvrir la
vidéo sur le peg ii the rocks d'accès
large tatouage